oh i love it look at this oh and he's
not made him
and more important
he's finished it he stuck it in the top
corner
absolutely incredible skills
hi it's harry redknapp here and this is
rate my skills at sport bible
oh my god move your feet down he don't
point at them he's pointing a bobble on
the pitch look incredible miss they've
laid it on the plate for him he's come
across
oh dear dear
that's unbelievable it's a great bit of
skill
great great bit of skill it was the most
skillful player you had at spurs would
you say luka modric was a fantastic
footballer he wasn't not doing tricks or
back hills or anything else but just
saw everything on the pitch didn't give
the ball away i used to play him off the
left and coming in that little pocket
you know
i moved him into central midfield and i
think that was really
you know i'm not saying i've changed his
career i didn't he'd done it himself but
that would have been a big part of the
change in him he went in the middle of
park and run games you know when i
decided to do it people at the club
you know who
coaching started he can't play in there
he's not strong enough and i moved him
in there um against arsenal on the uh on
a tuesday or wednesday night at home and
he run the game and then on the
saturdays i don't think you'll get away
with that again against chelsea balak
lampard essien
i said no he'd be right and he we beat
chelsea on the saturday and he run the
game again and never played anywhere
else again
oh my god oh my god
that is fantastic
oh i love it look at this oh and he's
not made him
and more important
he's finished it he stuck it in the top
corner
absolutely incredible skills
that was uh joe cole
as a kid joe would have been the best 11
year old footballer a 12 year old i'd
ever seen he was just incredible he was
just on another planet really
amazing he'd have been like messi or
someone as a kid when you see bits of
messi or maradona joe would have been
like that in that class
so that's a little like stoked against
man city do you remember that does that
from uh yeah from there you signed him a
lot yeah actually what what was it about
crouching that you liked the first time
i signed him at portsmouth
and it was a million pound qpr and the
chairman said to me milan hendrick and
milan said i mean you think i'm paying a
million pound for a basketball player
you're crazy he said he's the worst
footballer i've ever seen i said no he's
not i said he's going to be a good
player he was only 19 i think and we
signed him in the end after a lot of
arguments and he said to me if he's no
good to be you take the blame i said
yeah of course don't worry we had in one
season sold him at the end of that
season
for five million pound western villa and
milan said oh he said he was a good
player harry
oh
he liked that didn't he
great skill
good skill
first save okay second save fantastic
third save amazing
yeah
who was the best keeper that played
under you do you think oh difficult
difficult to say really um
david james was a great goalkeeper on
his day if he was on form he was almost
unbeatable
the year won the cup with
portsmouth he really he won the trophy
for us that year we got battered a
couple of times and
he kept us in the game really when we
should have been out of it you know
oh my god yeah that was lucky wasn't it
yeah dad's made a match-saving tackle
there though yeah yeah that was the best
tackle of the day that look at that
would you say is the best last ditch
defender that played under you the best
defender of all was bobby moore i played
with bobby and bobby was the best no one
like moro but he wasn't last ditch he
was just made it look easy the great
defenders are there
they're not making last-ditch tackles
they're they're reading situations
before they even develop and
those that you always see making last
ditch ones are probably in the wrong
position to start with and they're
making
last ditch tackles the real good ones
just read it you know
in third place cell would go the other
red kick was amazing bit of skill
great technique
in second place i would go with a corner
again fantastic clever looking the other
way bending the corner in
real real skill
and but the first for me was the the the
little guy little boy with the dribble
fantastic skill and that meg
and then the finish
was just amazing that was a great goal
i'd like to know where he is and where
he is now and i'd like to how old he is
now and what he's doing because
he looked like he could really play
you couldn't give this to a worse person
[Laughter]
i've never ever ever
used one of these or you know
just about use a telephone
[Music]
he's made a great run as well he just
can't stand his feet